Jake:来了来了来了
Jake: They're here, they're here, they're here.
Nicous: 哎帮帮忙啊哎呀
Nicous: Hey, help me out, come on.
Nicous: 帮我帮我瞧一瞧
Nicous: Help me, take a look.
Lucia:i should have mental
Lucia: I should have mental...
Nicous: 别让他拍
Nicous: Don't let him record.
Shure: 给你拍直接泡过去就好了
Katrina: 泡
Katrina: Record.
Shure: 或者你不直接塞啊
Shure: Or you can just stuff it in directly.
Lucia:哇好可爱这个腮红不让动啊
Lucia: Wow, so cute, don't mess with that blush.
Alice:哈哈哈你看这
Alice: Hahaha, look at this.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈哈我给他剪了个尾巴
Lucia: Hahahahaha, I cut its tail.
Katrina: 对啊就是乱骑
Katrina: Yeah, just riding around wildly.
Nicous: 是你刚才是地狱
Nicous: You were in hell just now.
Jake:要不走上去
Jake: How about we walk up?
Jake:帮我拿一下吧
Jake: Can you hold this for me?
Jake:来吧来谢谢你
Jake: Come on, thanks.
Katrina: 这是谁的背景啊我的吗
Katrina: Whose background is this? Mine?
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea.
Alice:我买的是桂花的
Alice: I bought the osmanthus one.
Alice:这是什么
Alice: What's this?
Lucia:白茶
Lucia: White tea.
Alice:白茶
Alice: White tea.
Lucia:上个厕所
Lucia: Need to use the bathroom.
Lucia:这不能录
Lucia: Can't record this.
Shure: 北冰洋
Shure: Arctic Ocean.
Shure: 北冰洋的熊猫
Shure: Panda of the Arctic Ocean.
Shure: 要加点香菜吗
Shure: Want to add some cilantro?
Lucia:我要其实我可以加
Lucia: Sure, I can add some.
Alice:他说是不是没给米饭
Lucia:这个米饭哦
Lucia: This rice, oh.
Alice: 这是我的吗
Alice: Is this mine?
Alice:这是我的吗
Katrina: 他不用吃饭
Katrina: He doesn't need to eat.
Shure: 妈的我是要吃饭
Shure: Damn, I need to eat.
Shure: 你等我吃饭完给构思一下
Shure: Wait till I'm done eating, then I'll think it over.
Jake:我还写了个曹喆许风行
Jake: I even wrote about Cao Zhe and Xu Fengxing.
Nicous: 让我来评判
Nicous: Let me judge.
Jake:你来评一评
Jake: You judge it.
Katrina: 哇我这里面没有筷子
Katrina: Wow, there's no chopsticks in here.
Shure: 确实有点
Shure: It really is a bit
Shure: 陶喆那个味
Shure: Like David Tao's style
Katrina: 还是陶喆那个
Katrina: Still like David Tao's
Katrina: 音色无法抗拒
Katrina: His voice is irresistible
Nicous: 不会做PPT
Nicous: Can't make a PPT
Katrina: 就是陶喆之间出轨然后
Katrina: It's just that David Tao's cheating scandal then
Katrina: 太抽像了
Katrina: It's too abstract
Alice:谁的鸡没拿
Alice: Whose chicken is missing?
Alice:谁的鸡
Alice: Whose chicken?
Lucia:这个
Lucia: This one
Alice: 这是你的吧
Alice: Is this yours?
Alice:说什么
Alice: What did you say?
Alice: 这里面还有这个呢
Alice: There's still this inside
Lucia:我撒了一个了
Lucia: I spilled one
Alice:你吃这个吗嘿嘿
Alice: Do you want to eat this? Haha
Alice:不是我逗你的
Alice: Just kidding
Alice:这有葱和香菜
Alice: There are scallions and cilantro
Alice:有人要吗
Alice: Does anyone want it?
Alice:还有好几包呢
Alice: There are several packs left
Alice:那边要吗
Alice: Does anyone over there want it?
Alice:是
Alice: Yes
Alice: 为什么
Alice: Why?
Lucia:刚刚女生突然发现我这有点亮
Lucia: Just now a girl suddenly noticed a bit of light here
Jake:那你的手机上怎么说
Jake: What does it say on your phone?
Lucia:她一直在searching
Lucia: It's still searching
Lucia:好那我确定我肯定这次开完为频了
Lucia: Okay, I'm sure I'll finish this video this time
Lucia:先点开VIP软件
Lucia: First open the VIP software
Jake:开机了是吧
Jake: Is it on?
Lucia:呃你说眼镜吗
Lucia: Uh, you mean the glasses?
Lucia:他现在没有灯亮着
Lucia: It's not showing any lights now
Lucia:我现在能按长按这个键吗
Lucia: Can I press and hold this button now?
Lucia:我长按一下
Lucia: I'll press and hold it
Lucia:它闪了一下绿光
Lucia: It flashed green
Lucia:然后又灭了
Lucia: Then it went off
Lucia:它又闪了一下绿光
Lucia: It flashed green again
Lucia:它又灭了
Lucia: Then it went off again
Jake:插了插了充电宝有电吗
Jake: Is it plugged into a power bank? Does the power bank have power?
Lucia:嗯好问题看一下
Lucia: Hmm, good question, let me check
Lucia:不会充电宝没电了
Lucia: Could it be that the power bank is out of battery?
Lucia:确实充电宝没电了
Lucia: Indeed, the power bank is out of battery
Lucia:好吧原因找到了
Lucia: Okay, we found the reason.